Prince Harry wishes Megan Markel a happy
38th birthday with a sweet message on
the couple's joint Instagram account he
wrote happy birthday to my amazing wife
thank you for joining me on this
adventure love H I'm so incredibly proud
of my wife Prince William and Kate
Middleton also shared on Instagram
wishing a very happy birthday to the
Duchess of Sussex today Megan's birthday
arrives after the couple's Instagram
account purged all of the accounts it
followed for a very special reason the
royal couple is asking fans for help to
highlight inspiring individuals and
organizations with their forces for
change campaign since announcing the
social media campaign in April Megan and
Harry have followed different accounts
each month based on a new theme in May
they featured Mental Health
Organization's June was focused on pride
and July was all about environmental
causes the campaign is looking for
someone you look up to the organization
doing amazing work that we should all be
following an account that inspires you
to be and do better or that simply makes
you feel good or the handle that brims
with optimism for a brighter tomorrow
the couple plan to follow 15 of the
suggested accounts on August 5th the day
after Megan's birthday my first to
change is Greta Sandberg my force for
change is here on the shoot it's Yara
Shahidi who me I think Chimamanda is
incredibly inspiring
of course Megan just revealed her own 15
forces for change in the September issue
of British Vogue which she guest edited
alongside editor-in-chief Edward and in
false I feel extremely privileged to
work with Edward and the Dutchess of
Sussex I love their complicity to make
this secret project such an example of
collaboration together and inclusiveness
[Applause]